hey everybody its charlie we got some
brand-new Game of Thrones season 8
episode 1 to break down there's some
early Easter eggs in advance of the
episode HBO dropped some official
details that give us some clues about
what's going on so we'll break it down
we're still doing the book giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video so what happened is is on HBO
scheduling website where it posts when
everything is happening where all the
episodes are airing it listed a bunch of
details for the first episode and this
is HBO's official website this isn't
like some fan site that's making this up
out of the blue they officially list the
run time at 60 minutes which lines up at
the report that we got a little while
ago about all the run times and then was
corroborated later by what HBO and Casey
Blois said in a recent interview with
the tcas
if you don't remember the video that I
did for all the different runtimes after
that happened HBO officially came out
and said not all these are exact some of
these will change and some of them will
be closer to time meaning they'll
actually be shorter so I'm actually
being more conservative with my episode
links most of the episodes seemed like
they were gonna be close to 80 minutes
long now HBO is saying that it's gonna
be closer to time so now it sounds like
the episodes are gonna be a little bit
shorter but we'll get more information
about that when we get closer to that
dropping the more interesting part of
this or the cast members that appear
during episode 1 in the cast members
that do not there's some very big
characters during season 8 that
seemingly do not appear during episode 1
so I just broke this down top 10 style
starting with number 10 tormund in beric
Dondarrion are listed in the episode
last seen in episode 7 in the finale
running down the wall when the night
came destroyed it with Vissarion in the
white walker army marched south over the
border number 9 Edie is also listed last
seen during season 7 episode 1 when he
was letting brand through the gate at
Castle black
presumably Edie in the skeleton crew to
make as many white Walker white puns as
possible stay to Castle black while the
business at eastwatch-by-the-sea with
the wildlings in the night King and the
army of the Dead was going on during
season 7 so is that the beginning of
season 8 there are still nights watch
brothers that are alive but because the
night king destroyed the wall and they
probably heard about it since then
there's not much point in them defending
the wall if the thing that they were
defending against is running around in
the south terrorizing the
realm so presumably Edie and the other
knights watch brothers that are alive
would head down to Winterfell before the
next big battle and as for torment and
beric either they stole a couple horses
and made for Castle black to let them
know what happened if they didn't send
any Ravens or did they just made a
beeline for Winterfell themselves number
eight Melisandre is listed as being in
the episode last seen during season
seven episode three having that
conversation with Varys once scaring the
crap out of him and telling him that she
was headed to volantis but that she
would be back because it was all
destined to go down the war for the dawn
in Westeros so she was basically telling
Varys that they were destined to die and
that's what shook him and it is really
hard to imagine something out there that
could actually shock or scare Varys a
pretty say bit that Melisandre was going
to volantis to get more red priests and
priestesses from the red temple to get
reinforcements and maybe the fiery hand
there like the faith militant of the red
temples that are usually stationed
outside the red temples wherever the
temples are around the world to keep
people from causing problems or if
anybody needs to be put down just
general badasses in the service of the
faith the same way the faith militant
will serve the highest Sparrow but
remember the last time that Melisandre
was in Winterfell Jon's like don't you
ever come back here or there's gonna be
big problems so it'll be interesting to
see what happens when she has her
reunion quote-unquote with Jon Snow and
even better blasts from the past
also listed on episode 1 is Gendry so
what kind of a reunion can you imagine
they're going to have with Arya kendry
and Melisandre all in the same place and
if Jon Snow doesn't like her then
imagine how kendra feels after season 3
with all the leeches and remember that
last meeting with arya in the fact that
Melisandre is on Arya's list and
presumably she's making her way to
Winterfell so put them in proximity to
each other and just see who kills
Melisandre first in fact I would be
willing to bet that Arya is probably a
bigger threat to Melisandre than the
White Walkers in the night King you know
obviously should go without saying
because they're saying the Gendry is an
episode one that also implies you get
the Arya again reunion that we've been
wondering about for the last couple of
seasons since Arya came back to Westeros
we'll see which reunion winds up being
the most awkward Melisandre area in
Gendry or bran and Jaime
we will meet again things I do for love
but number seven Yara Greyjoy also
listed during episode one last seen in
Chains being taken to the black cells in
King's Landing by euron greyjoy in
Episode three also number six listed in
episode 1 is euron greyjoy last seen
during episode 7 sailing to Essos to
pick up the golden company for Cersei
and bring them back to King's Landing he
set sail the minute he told everyone to
screw off in the dragon pit
this was Sousou revealed later that
night to Jaime oh he's already sailed to
go pick up the golden company this has
been in play for a long time now we
don't know how long they're gonna drag
on this Ironborn Ark so as for how long
you're on Greyjoy is going to survive
during the season because I do believe
that Theon and Yara are destined to kill
him in Theon will sort of reclaim some
of his honor some of his manhood not
literally because he's not gonna get
that back but it seems like a lot of the
bigger characters will make it till
later in the season so all bets are off
as to when they finally get you're on
Greyjoy but you're on is pretty high on
my death predictions list number 5 the
sweet Robin is listed in the cast he's
been in the Vale ever since we last saw
him in season 6 episode 4 when
Littlefinger convinced him to send the
armies of the Vale to help bolster Jon
Snow's Northern Alliance they arrived
just in the nick of time during the
Battle of the bastards in episode 9 but
we didn't see sweet Robin after episode
4 he's not really high on my death
predictions list but ultimately they
could choose to try and marry him to
Sansa if she's not going to marry
someone else because I do believe that
she'll survive and ultimately become the
lady of Winterfell proper like she
wanted to shall become the sort of
warden s of the north but she'll also
have to get married to another suitable
person is there only a handful of those
on the show right now that aren't really
high on my death predictions list
they're all out of eligible bachelors
but I definitely think a lot of them are
gonna wind up dying technically I think
she's still married to Tyrion - they'll
probably have a joke about that but I
don't know if that will stick or if
Tyrion winds up surviving they'll
actually try to make it work but I'm
sure they'll address that in the first
couple of episodes when they have their
reunion number for a Lascar Stark and
Ned umber are listed our IP say an early
warning for them last seen bending the
knee to Jon Snow in season 7 episode 1
they're really young they were given
their lands back but the reason why
they're pretty much due
is because their lands the umbers last
heart is the first thing in the path of
the night king of the White Walkers on
their way down to Winterfell in the
Karstarks land is right next to that you
have to assume that the night king is
gonna try and pick up every last living
thing that he can and add it to the
forces of the army of the Dead on his
way down to Winterfell so that means
that pretty much anything in this region
is doomed unless they make a beeline for
Winterfell number three the little bear
is confirmed in the cast list so still
holding out hope for a reunion with
Jorah Mormont
last seen in the north fleeing Ned
Stark's justice after Ned caught him
slaving his own people don't know who's
gonna bear him more ill-will the other
lords of the north that probably think
he's terrible or the little bear and the
other people at Bear Island like how
dare you show your face here after what
you did to your people and then ran like
a coward number two really big surprise
Edmure Tully is listed in the cast last
seen during season six episode 10 when
he was just mentioned by the still then
alive Walder Frey's saying that he was
keeping him in a Cell because it
wouldn't be right to execute his
son-in-law
but when Arya executed all the male
phrase by wearing Walder Frey's face she
didn't mention anything about letting
him out so there's still a lot of female
Frey women that could have let him out
of the dungeon if they did not and he's
still chilling in that cell as at the
beginning of the season maybe Jaime
could help him get out as he's making
his way slowly up to Winterfell number
one though noticeably absent really big
characters from this cast list or the
actor that plays the night king he
supposedly does not appear during
episode one in Harry Strickland which is
the name of the character that's going
to be the leader of the golden company
so either their omission is just an
error like there just wasn't room to
include them which doesn't seem quite as
plausible or they really don't appear
during episode one and they just find
some other way to show what's going on
with that like you see the army of the
Dead marching but you don't see the
actual night king himself and maybe you
see you're on with the golden company or
talking about the golden company but for
some reason the leader of the golden
company just isn't in that shot and
that's why he's not listed in the cast
list also important to remember that
they don't always list every single big
character so a really good example is
ghost in the direwolves they're huge
characters for the story and we know
that ghost is going to be appearing
during season eight episodes but when
you see these little text blurbs saying
oh these are all the actors and the
characters that are going to be
appearing during the up
so they don't always list the animal
actors or some of the more minor
characters but let me know in the
comments which of these surprise
returning characters are you most
excited to see come back to the show I
know people have been asking about Ed
mirror for a while now like you're just
chilling out in that fray cell hopefully
some of those women let him out but
what'll happen is is it seems like HBO
is ramping up to release an actual
season 8 trailer sometime in the next
couple of weeks maybe around the Oscars
something like that towards the end of
the month so just be on high alert for
the next couple of weeks for a game of
Thrones trailer congratulations Tom
Smith you're the giveaway winner from my
last big Game of Thrones video please
email me on the about page my channel so
I can get your details click here for my
new Game of Thrones deleted scenes video
and click here for all my Game of
Thrones season 8 teasers trailers and
promo videos thank you so much for
watching
everybody stay awesome we'll see you
guys tonight
you